[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to our
podcast on the series called High School
memories my name is Bley and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive in into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired because today's topic will be
about mental health
awareness I personally wanted to talk
about this topic because nowadays it has
become a significant problem for people
of all ages the prevailance of mental
health issues is alarming and it's
crucial for us to open up a dialogue
about it from the constant pressures of
suicidal expectations to the challenges
posed by digital age we're navigating a
complex landscapes that impacts our
minds people with quote unquote a weak
mind tend to experience higher level of
anxiety stress and even prevalent
suicidal thoughts it's a STK reality
that mental health struggles can impact
anyone regardless of age or
background persistent stressers ranging
from academic pressures to social
expectations contribute to intrate web
of challenges affecting our mental
well-being
furthermore Recent research from Harvard
University delves into the specific
stresses faced by college students
revealing that the transition from high
school to college can be a particularly
challenging period for mental health the
pressure to perform academically coupled
with a new found Independence creates a
unique set of challenges recognizing and
addressing these challenges is PIV
pivotal in fostering a supported
environment for young minds conversely
individuals with a healthy mental state
often experience more success and
happiness in life along with a better
physical health the World Health
Organization or wh emphasizes the
positive impact of good mental health on
overall well-being according to their
research individuals with a robust
mental health or more likely to achieve
overall educational and employment goals
contributing to a more prous and
fulfilling life expanding all this let's
delve into the roles of positive mental
health in fostering
resilience understanding and promoting
resilient factors such as social support
and adapted coping strategies can
Empower individuals to navigate life
challenges with a greater sense of
wellbeing now let's go into the prim
primary influencers on Mental Health
examine both the det detrial factors
that POS challenges and the positive
elements that could contribute to a
thriving
mind several factors can adversely
affect mental health such as the persu
persuasive influence of social media the
use of nicotine products drugs and other
external external
pressures recognizing these factors
allow us to make informed choices about
their digital consumption and prioritize
mental
wellbeing also professors at MIT
concluded their research the researchers
sped the standard roll out of Facebook
in colleges with 430,000 responses from
the National College Health assessment a
semiannual survey of mental health and
well-being compasses across the
US the survey looks at other dimensions
of student health as well as substant
use and exercise
habits the researchers found a
significant link between the presence of
Facebook and the deterioration in mental
health among college students the emphas
is is on the need for a holistic
approach to mental health awareness
taking into account cultural and so
societal factors on the other side there
are proactive steps we can take to
improve mental health practices like
meditation reading or praying have
proven to be powerful Tools in fostering
mental
well-being moreover a comprehensive
review of literature delves into the
impact of religious practices such as
prayer on Mental Health providing
insight into the role of spiritually in
mental
well-being in a review published in the
journal J ma International medicine
researchers reviewed that more than
18,000 scientific studies looking at the
relationship between meditation and
depression and anxiety 47 trials with
date on 35 15 patients have other
criteria for well-designed research the
results show that that month for
meditation programs over an 8we period
had moderate evidence a reducing
symptoms of depression and anxiety
another study published in the general
psych research found that individuals
with generaliz anxiety disorder who
participated in the mindfulness based
stress reduction and BSR program had the
greater reduction in stress makers than
a controlled
group all right so with the studies and
the journals let's dish into let's dish
the numbers and jump into the real stuff
the stories that happen in the everyday
life so I got to tell you about this
amazing journey I've been on picture
this I used to be stuck in this
NeverEnding social media Loop feeling
down and out I mean who wouldn't when
all you see are these pictures perfect
lives on your feet right I got to a
point where I was drained both mentally
and physically low energy and and not
EXA exactly feeling great about myself
but here's the game changer I decided to
hit the brakes on the social media
circus unplugged logged out and just
breathed for a bit and you won't believe
the difference it made I started diving
into physical activities and even got
into praying like who knew a bit of
peace and quiet could be so powerful now
here's where it gets really cool my life
did a whole 180 no more dragging myself
throughout the day with low energy I
started looking after myself getting
active and guess what now got this whole
new physique going on I'm talking
healthier more energetic and even
starting to focus and concentrate easier
and it turns out it's just about tuning
out the noise and tuning into yourself
the glow up is real my friend and all
started with a little Le a little less
screen time and a lot more discipline
and
self-love so taking care of your mental
health is like giving your mind a SPO
day you're not you're more focused your
happiness levels hit the roof and
suddenly life feel a bit more awesome
it's not some abstract concept it's the
key to living your best most kickass
life so yeah mental health is kind of a
big deal it's the magic ingredient that
makes everything else in your life taste
a lot whole
better some tips for me personally are
one dopamine detox you can do you can do
your own research but but basically
lower your screen time two read some
psychological psychological or
philosophy books number three join
activities preferably Out outdoors
sports or even better competitive Sports
and forth depending in your religion
pray it definitely worked out for me so
as we wrap up today's episode I invite
each of you to join the movement for
battle Mental Health Health let's Foster
empathy understanding and resilience
let's hel on the status quo and advocate
for mental health education support
system and accessible resources together
let's embark on a journey towards a
brighter mentally healthier future
remember it starts with conversation
understanding and the collective
commitment to making mental health a
prior to priority in our lives and in
the lives of those around us thank you
so much for joining us on this episode
of high school memories it's been an
incredible journey and we're so glad you
came along for the ride until next time
take
[Music]
care
oh